WE ARE THE INCREDIBLY EARLY
THEN ON TIME ROLES COMMITTEE
AND WHAT IN IN AUDIENCE. OF
PEOPLE READY TO GO THANK YOU SO
WITH THAT LET ME ASK MADAM
SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES BATES HERE
MONNING HERE MONNING HERE ROB
YOUR RAFI HERE WILK HERE WILK
AT HERE AT AND I HAVE SAID
WE'RE CALL THE WIND MARCH A
RULES COME TO ORDER SO I FOR
THE RECORD SO BUT WE GO THE
APPOINT I AM TO. CAN SEE CAL OF
ITEMS THE BILL WERE. OF ITEMS
THROUGH THE FLOOR
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS. SHOW ME. THANK
YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
MANAGED PLEASE CALL ROLL
SENATORS BATES. BATES AYE
MONNING MONNING I. ROTH I WILL
WRITE WILK AYE AYE HI AND SO
THANK YOU SO WE WILL GO A AND
START THE FOR. COM FOR MISS CAN
JOHN IF YOU TO COME UP. TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL. AND WE
INVITE YOU TO ACKNOWLEDGING YOU
WOULD TO THE HERE AN SPECIAL
YOU TODAY AT THEN OPEN COM AND
THEN WE WILL GO RIGHT IN THE-
IN QUESTIONS THE ROLE COMMITTEE.
WELCOME. OKAY OKAY THANK YOU
PRESIDENT PRO TEM AND MEMBERS
I'D JUST LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE GOVERNOR FOR THIS
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY AN HONOR
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THIS LEADERSHIP
CAPACITY. I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE- COMMITTED TO FAMILY
FRIENDS MENTORS AND COLLEAGUES
APPRECIATE THEM FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO BE HERE TODAY. I
ESPECIALLY WANT TO RECOGNIZE MY
LIFELONG FRIEND. MY SISTER AND
FATHER FOR BEING HERE AND FOR
THEIR CONTINUED LOVE AND
SUPPORT. MEDICAL
FAMILY AN APP ALSO MY WONDERFUL
HAS BEEN AND CARING KIND IN
BRILLIANT THREE CHILDREN ARE
WITH US AND I APPRECIATE THEIR
GENEROSITY AS THEY SHARE THEIR
TIME WITH ME I WITH THE
INDIVIDUALS CHILDREN FAMILIES
WHO MIGHT HAVE THE PRIVILEGE TO
SERVE. THE MISSION OF THE CAL
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
IS TO SERVE TO AID IN PROTECT
MEDIAN VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND
ADULTS. PUT SIMPLY THIS IS MY
PURPOSE. I RECOGNIZE THE
TREMENDOUS BREATH OF
RESPONSIBILITY THIS DEPARTMENT
HAS AND RECOGNIZE HOW MUCH OUR
APPROACH IS TO SERVICE MATTER.
WE'VE BEEN MAKING MEANINGFUL
PROGRESS THAT I WILL CONTINUE
TO MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER WE
CONTINUE TO IDENTIFY HOW TO
BEST SUPPORT THE CHILD WHO
ENTERS OUR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
OUR ELDERS IN INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE DISABLED OR BLIND TO WRITE
PROVIDE THEM WITH OPPORTUNITIES
TO REMAIN SAFELY IN THEIR HOME.
AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO OUT OF
HOME CARE. AND WE ENSURE THAT
THERE IS A CONTINUUM OF CARE
AVAILABLE FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
AND FINALLY WE CONTINUE TO
IDENTIFY HOW TO BEST SUPPORT
FAMILIES WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
POVERTY AND FACING
HOMELESSNESS. VIA FAMILY AND
HOUSING FIRST PURCHASE. BEFORE
JOINING SOCIAL SERVICES FIVE
YEARS AGO I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER PRIMARILY
IN THE NONPROFIT SECTOR.
WORKING WITH CAN YOU ON THE
ISSUE TWENTY IN THE- CHILDREN
AND FAMILY HAVE THE RE. THEY
NEED TO THRIVE. I WILL
PRIORITIZE THE INTEGRATION AT
THE SAFE THE RARE ARE. TO KEEP.
SHE HE AND AS A STRESS TO
REDUCE. TIMIDLY AND LISTENING.
I WILL ALSO IN BAD AT IN A
AGENT PRINCIPLES CAN. CALLAND
DAY DRIVEN APPROACH IS TO OUR
WORK TO ENSURE ALL OF US KNOW
WHERE WE ARE MEETING OUR- AND
FOR. AND WHERE WE TO MAKE.
ADJUSTMENTS ALONG THE WAY. IN
MY EXPERIENCE WORKING ON SYSTEM
CHANGE MULTIPLE AT THE LOCAL
STATE NOW LEVEL I KNOW STATE
COUNTY GA. COMMUNITY OR- AND
OTHERS. OFTEN HAVE MUCH MORE IN
COMMON THAN NOT. AND I AM
COMMITTED TO BRINGING A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH WITH
PARTNERS TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO STRENGTHEN ITS
ROBUST. AND COMPREHENSIVE ARRAY
OF SERVICES WITH AN FOR THE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED US MOST.
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING LET ME
START WITH YOU TODAY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND- MISS JOHNSON I
WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU ON
YOUR APPOINTMENT THANK YOU FOR
STEPPING UP I KNOW YOU IN OUR
CONVERSATION YOU'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OVERLAP WITH THE
PRIOR DIRECTOR- WILL LIGHT BORN
AND- WHEN I LOOK AT THE
ORGANIZATIONAL CHART IT'S
REALLY QUITE DONE THING HAND.
YET YOU. OF BUT CALM PRO IN A
GREAT DEAL OF NON AMERICA. YES
ONE THING THAT I THINK IS.
CURRENTLY IS AS WE ADAPT TO
THE- CORONA VIRUS THE COVERT
NINETEEN HE SHARED SOME OF WHAT
FALLS UNDER YOUR DEPARTMENTS
CONCERNED PARTICULARLY. AT RISK
COMMUNITIES- AND MAYBE YOU
COULD SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND LITTLE BIT THE STEPS THAT
YOU WERE TAKING IMMEDIATELY- IN
ANTICIPATION OF THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH RISK THANK YOU SENATOR I
ABSOLUTELY THE DEPARTMENT- IS
PART AB LARGE AT A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT THAT'S
OCCURRING ACROSS THE STATE
RIGHT NOW. AT TO SUPPORT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF ALL OF US
AND I WANT TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
OUR SISTER AGENCY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
DOING A TREMENDOUS JOB AND
CERTAINLY LEADING US ALONG THE
WAY. AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES HAS A
REPATRIATION RESPONSIBILITIES
AND SO ANY- INDIVIDUALS AYE
REPATRIATING BACK TO THE UNITED
STATES WE SUPPORT THAT
OPERATION TO OUR COUNTIES. IT
CERTAINLY ADDS THAT THE AIR BAG
REGIONAL EVENTS OCCUR WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PAGE READING
INTO THE FOR REAL HIGH. WE WERE
THE IN SO BE NEXT BERNADINE ME
AT LOOKING TO SUPPORT THAT
EFFORT DEVELOPING SHELTER THAT
OPERATION READ. TO ANOTHER THAT
WAS BUT SO BUT ONLY WE'VE
CONTINUED TO THINK THROUGH WHAT
SHALL AND SUPPORT SENATE HOW SO.
I ANY OF END OF THAT HAVE BEEN.
WILL NEED. ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE
OUR THE IN THE AT RISK. TO
ENSURE THAT ALL OF THE LICENSE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA UNDERSTAND
PROTOCOLS AND PROCEDURES THEY
NEED TO TAKE. A SO WE HAVE PUT
OUT GUIDANCE TO A DILLON SENIOR
CARE FOR. A CARE FOR IN
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS PER. BOTH AT.
FOR THIS BUT ALSO FOR STAFF IN
THE FEE SUPPORT THOSE OP. IN
AND THOSE OP. XIN IT IS KEEP
MOST IMPORTANCE AROUND AT HAND
WASHING AND UNDER HAVE CONTROL
BUT ALSO THE WHY. ARE IT HE TO
THEIR WRIST TO REAP AT TO ASK
ATTY INSTANT THAT ARE AT SEE SO
WE HAVE BEEN IN A CONCERT CASE
FAQ. I WORKING WITH LOCAL
HEALTH THE AS WELL AS OURS
PUBLIC THE IN RISK. TO ANY IS
THAT HAVE. ARISEN WANT TO APPS
SENT. TO THE AT AT HERE IN A
SACRAMENTO OF THE LAW. OF AT
LAST NIGHT. I AM IN A AND
SENIOR FOR SO WE ARE TAKING THE
MEAT STEP TO ALL ENJOY THAT BUT-
OUT PROBLEM. AND STAY OF A IS
BE FOLLOWED WE WORK. ADDITIONAL
FOR. IS INCLUDING BEING ABLE TO
RESTRICT VISITORS FROM THOSE
FACILITIES AND MAKING SURE
STAFF ARE TAKING THE
APPROPRIATE STEPS AND NOT
ARRIVING TO WORK SICK AND SO
FORTH SO THERE'S A NUMBER. OF
PLACES WHERE WITH OUR LICENSE
FACILITIES WERE ON THE GROUND
AND SUPPORTING THAT OPERATION
THANK YOU AND- WE ALSO TALKED
IN LIGHT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
STATE OF THE STATE IN FOCUS ON.
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES- YOU SHARED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT'S ROLE IN HELPING-
AN AT RISK FAMILY MAY MOBILIZE
RANT SO THERE THEY DON'T LOSE.
AND THEN SOME OF THE WORK WITH
BOARD AND CARE FACILITY COULD
YOU SHARE A LITTLE BIT OF THAT.
SENATOR I WE ARE PUT A SEVEN
HUNDRED AND MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT- IN THE CALIFORNIA
ACCESS TO HOUSING FIND AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
WOULD ADMINISTER AND AS YOU
SAID. THERE ARE THREE MAIN
PURPOSES THERE AT AND
SUPPORTING. THE IMMEDIATE NEED
FOR RENT SUBSIDIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO SUPPORT THEM
FROM BOTH COMING OFF OF THE
STREET BUT ALSO PREVENT THEM
FROM BECOMING HOMELESS. IT'S
ALSO TO DEVELOP AFFORDABLE
HOUSINGAND TO SUPPORT UNSTABLE
OUR DON'T SENIOR CARE
FACILITIES SO NOW WE HAVE
ACTUALLY JUST RELEASED. A
REVISED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
INTO ACCOUNT SOME OF THE
FEEDBACK WE'VE HEARD FOR. OTHER
LET'S JUST AS WELL STATE AT
THIS. TO ALSO IN THAT ARE. A OP.
WITH I OTHERS TO BILL ON THE
WAY THAT IS BEEN COULD HAVE
THIS ARE YOU TAKING PLACE WITH
THE- DOLLAR. THAT HAS MADE IN
PRIOR YEAR SO WE ARE AT. ACTS
TO WORK ON AND EFFORT REALLY
LOW AT HOW WE CAN. FURTHER STAY
THE PLACE OF THAT HOUSING BY
INTEGRATING SOCIAL SERVICES AS
PART OF THE SOLUTION- AT SO
THAT WAS THE WE'RE WE'RE AT I
WAS CERTAINLY GOING TO BE A
PART OF A LARGE EFFORT IN THIS
SPACE TO WHERE THE HOMELESS IN
COORDINATING. COUNCIL WILL BE A
CONSULTING WITH ON VARIOUS
LEVELS IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THIS INITIATIVE ALSO WITH THAT.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMPONENT OF
THE INITIATIVE AND THE DATA
COLLECTION AND REPORTING TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE SOME
ALIGNMENT ACROSS ACROSS OUR
VARIOUS PROGRAMS. THANK YOU
NINE I ALSO JUST WANTED
KNOWLEDGE. YOUR WORK IN YOUR
PREDECESSORS WORK WAS
STAKEHOLDER. AND I THINK A LOT
OF THE SUCCESS OF THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN THAT.
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. BUILDING
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND TRUST
THAT HELPS IMPLEMENT POLICY IN
PERFECT POLICY SO. AGAIN THANK
YOU I MEANT TO LEAD WITH THIS
BUT ALL CLOSE BY. THANKING YOUR
FAMILY FOR BEING HERE TODAY AND
FOR THEIR SUPPORT- CALIFORNIANS
DEPENDING ON YOU A LINE AND SO
WE THINK YOUR FAMILY FOR THEIR
SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. WONDER SENATOR BAYH.
THANK YOU ARE CAN GRADUALLY
LINE NAM AND HANG ON I ALKYL
THE COMMENTS OF MY CALL ON
WOULD YOU KNOW IS SUPPORT FOR
YOUR FAMILY WHAT YOU'VE IS NOT
THE SAME I WORKED FOR IN THE
SICK. IT IS A LONG WAY AND I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE PASS AND YOUR
IN IN AND SEND YOU LEFT IS
CERTAINLY ON YOU KNOW CHAU AND
NOW THOUGHT SOMETHING IN TO BE
OF PROGRAM PRIDE THAT HAVE BEEN
UNDER TAKE I HAVE A WE HAD A
WINTER COME AND I SHARED DAYS I
YOU KNOW I THERE ON THE.
INTERVIEW THOSE CLIENTS THAT
HOPE TO HELP THEM THAN PER. WE
ABLE TO DO IN THOSE. BUT I
DIDN'T TO ASK YOU WE- ADDED.
RESOURCES BOTH. AID AND ASSET.
IN OF OUR WORK FOLKS DO WE HAVE
A DATA SHOWING A THAT IS HELP
TO MAKE IT. IN TERMS OF MOVIE
TOWARDS A- AND CERTAINLY
MEETING THERE ARE THEIR BASE ME
OF THEIR ALWAYS BEEN A VERY
HUGE CONCERN. THAT THE- AMOUNT
AND THE AT. DETERMINING WAS
REALLY. TIE IN A IN A- ME WERE
WITH SUCH AN INCREASE IN THE
COST OF LIVING. YES SIR I'VE
WERE. THAT WERE MADE THIS AT
HERE'S TO THE B. IMPLEMENT AS
WE SEE BOTH THE GRANT INCREASE
BUT AS YOU SAID ALSO. I
INCREASINGLY OF DOLLAR. THAT
ARE PARTICIPANTS IN THE PRO CAN
MEET. AS THEY BECOME. AND WORK
TOWARDS THE- I THINK WHAT WE
LEARN WHICH AT FUND. THING THAT
WE'VE INCREASE THE MINIMUM BY
AS WE'VE THAT WE HAD TO LOOK AT.
KIND OF THE ENTRY AND EXIT.
WITH COST OF AND- TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THE WHAT IT. TO THE TO
MAKE IT HE HAD MICHAEL AND BE
THE- SO. I WE ARE IN THE OF A-
AB CHAIN PART. AT WITH OUR
AUTUMN. THAT NEEDS TO BE
UPDATED TO ALLOW FOR THOSE TO
OCCUR BUT THAT'S WE WILL. BE UP
WITH A MACAU MONTHS. TO REPORT
BACK ON. GREAT IN ONE OTHER I'D
THAT CAME UP STEPS OF TO OUR OF.
HE IS THE RATE. THAT ARE HAVING
TO BE. APPROVED OR- THE BILL A
TEMP IN BED AND I GUESS
THURMOND SOME. YOU LATE. IN THE.
AT APPROVAL ARE YOU AWARE OF
THAT AND IF NOT WHAT WOULD BE
YOUR APPROACH- WHEN YOU GET
BACK TO THE OFFICE. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION WE ABSOLUTELY
DO NOT WANT TO BE IMPLEMENTING
ANYTHING THAT'S NOT AND
CURRENTS I REGULATION STATUTE
AND CERTAINLY THAT SHOULDN'T
OCCUR INSIDE I WELCOME ALL THAT
FEEDBACK DIRECTLY TO ME IS TO
ENSURE THAT THAT'S NOT
OCCURRING. I WHAT WE DO IN OUR
LICENSE TO SELL THESE AS WERE
PROPOSING REGULATIONS. ALONG
THE WAY AN ENGAGING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE
REGULATIONS- IS CERTAINLY TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND SUPPORT TO LICENCES TO GIVE
THEM A SENSE POTENTIALLY HAVE
ANY DIRECTION THAT WE'RE GOING
OUT IN ANY GIVEN WAY BUT- IT'S
NOT ABOUT- IN FORCING IT'S
ABOUT. HELPING THEM UNDERSTAND
WHERE WHAT AREAS WILL BE
FOCUSED ON IN PRIORITIZING FOR
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THOSE
IN THEIR CARE SO BUT CERTAINLY
WE SHOULDN'T BE IMPLEMENTING
ANYTHING THAT'S NOT ALREADY
PART OF OUR REGULATORY OR
STATUTORY. I WAS ASSURED THAT
THAT WOULD BE YOUR ANSWER- I
THINK YOU ALL SHOULD KNOW THAT
MS JOHNSON SPENT AN HOUR I
THINK AN HOUR AND A HALF THIS
MORNING IN ANOTHER HEARING I
WAS IN BREADTH OF KNOWLEDGE ON
TO ONE OF THE MOST COMPLEX
AGENCIES TO ADDRESS THE MOST
VULNERABLE. IN OUR COMMUNITIES
IS INCREDIBLE. SO YOU HAVE A
VERY STRONG HI FOR ME FOR YOUR
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRO TEM
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT- VERY IMPRESSED
WITH YOU DURING OUR
CONVERSATION SO I KNOW THAT I
KNOW THAT YOU ARE DEFINITELY UP
FOR UP FOR THE TEST SO I AGREE
WITH ALL MY COLLEAGUES- ONE
THING THAT WE DID TALK ABOUT
THAT LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
PUBLICLY SO NETFLIX IS NOW COME
OUT WITH THIS NEW MINI SERIES
THE TRIALS OF GABRIEL FERNANDES.
A YOUNG BOY THAT WAS. MURDERED
BY HIS MOTHER AND BOYFRIEND.
AND IT HAPPENED MY DISTRICT.
AND PARTIALLY IS NOT THE ONLY
ONE WE LOSS AND THE AT HAVE A
LOS AND WE'VE JUST RECENTLY
LOST NO CLASSROOM- AS WOMEN
LACKEY MYSELF AS YOU KNOW WERE
ABLE TO GET APPROVED AN AUDIT
WELL BACK IN THOSE FINDINGS
CAME BACK FOR THE STATE AUDITOR
AND THEY WEREN'T VERY
COMPLIMENTARY. TO THE LA COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS OUT OF FAMILY
SERVICES SO AS DIRECTOR YOU
COULD TELL ME ABOUT YOUR
OVERSIGHT OF THESE COUNTY
OFFICES. AND INTO AS IT RELATES
DIRECTLY TO THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT THE AUDITOR. HAS MADE IN
HER REPORT WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE-
RECOMMENDATIONS GET
IMPLEMENTED. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SENATOR IN AND LET ME
JUST START BY AGAIN-
RECOGNIZING THE TRAGEDIES THAT
HAVE OCCURRED- AND CERTAINLY
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE AS WE ARE.
LOOKING AT ANY GIVEN TRAGEDY
SUCH AS THOSE THAT YOU JUST-
IDENTIFIED OUR RESPONSE IS TO
GO OUT AND UNDERSTAND IN WHAT
HE SAID HAND IN HAND WITH THE
COUNTY TO UNDERSTAND THE STEPS.
THAT WERE TAKEN OR POTENTIALLY-
NOT TAKEN- IN IN IN SOME OF
THESE CASES- ALONG THE WAY AND
SO THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'VE
DONE- WE AS PART OF OUR
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITIES HAVE
A NUMBER OF WAYS THAT WE ARE
MONITORING COMPLIANCE- AROUND
TIMELINESS AROUND. A USING THE
STRUCTURE DECISION MAKING TOOL
FOR COUNTIES- WE ARE RECEIVING
QUARTERLY REPORTS AND HAVE
QUARTER QUARTERLY A CONTACT
WITH COUNTIES AROUND THESE
PARTICULAR GIVEN DATA POINTS
THAT WERE SAYING THAT AREN'T
MATCHING THAT WE'VE QUESTIONS
RELATED TO. HOW WE ALSO ARE OF
COURSE ARE MONITORING TO SYSTEM
TREATMENT PLAN OF PART OF OUR
APPS THE OUR- FAMILY SERVICE
REVIEW PROCESS SO THERE'S NO
HUESO WERE CAUGHT. COMMUNICATE
IN ASSESSING WHAT'S WHAT'S
OCCURRING IN COMMUNICATION WORK
WERE THERE THERE HAVE BEEN
THESE FATALITIES IT HAS BEEN
OUR PRACTICE TO ACTUALLY DEPLOY
TO THE COMMUNITY. AND ASSIST
INTO YOUR POINT. A RELATED TO
THE AUDIT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE
LOOKED AT THE OPPORTUNITIES TO.
DO OUR REVIEW SOME OF THIS AREA
THAT HAVE RAISED BY THE AUDITOR.
I DIDN'T FIVE WHICH THOSE WE
ALSO WERE TO AND- IN THAT
PROGRAM IMPROVEMENT PLAN SO
THAT WE HAVE AN ABILITY TO
MONITOR OPEN THE WAY AS WELL. I
WILL TELL YOU. THAT SOME OF THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT THAT WE FOR. IN LAW
ANGELES WHICH REALLY ALL ABOUT.
AT A PRACTICE. SO AT FROM A
WHAT WE LEARNED TODAY IN IN
THESE INSTANCES IT'S NOT THAT
THE PROCESS ITSELF WAS
NECESSARILY FOLLOW IT WAS THAT
IT WASN'T FOLLOWED. AND SO
THAT'S WHERE AT WERE ENGAGED IN
UNDERSTANDING THE STEPS AND
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS THAT THE
COUNTY WILL TAKE AND I CAN TELL
YOU IN THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS
ALONE THERE'S BEEN. SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT- IN THAT COMPLIANCE
IN THE TIMELINESS OF RESPONSE
SO THAT IT IS ABSOLUTELY- MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE UNDERSTANDING IN ANY OF
THESE INSTANCES WHAT IS
OCCURRING THAT WERE. ASSESSING
THAT AN ON GOING BASIS AND ARE
COMMITTED AGAIN TO WALK HAND IN
HAND WITH THE COUNTY TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE. EXPERIENCING THESE
AGAIN. THERE THANK YOU FOR THAT
WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT FOSTER
YOUTH IN HOMELESSNESS AND I.
AND I LIKE YOUR VISION AND JUST
YOU KNOW YOUR YOUR PASSION
JUST. KEEP SAUDI WHICH- AND
MAKES A GOOD THING BECAUSE
YOU'VE GOT YOU'VE GOT A VERY
HEAVY LIVE SO- AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS WE'LL BE
SUPPORTING. SUPPORTING YOU IN
THE VOTE COMES UP WHEN THE TIME
IS APPROPRIATE MADAM CHAIR I'D
LIKE TO MOVE THAT NOMINATION.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
ON SENATOR OFFICE THINK YOU'VE
BEEN PUT ON NOTICE. EFFECTIVELY
ON WHO WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION. WITH THAT THE SITTER TO
ROSS GO GO HEAD THANK YOU
ABSOLUTELY NO QUESTIONS THANK
YOU FOR SERVING. MADAM DIRECTOR
LOOK FORWARD TO VOTING I. THANK
YOU- I WANT TO START BY SAYING
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT WAS
DONE IN SAN DIEGO- AS IT
RELATES TO THE ASYLUM SEEKERS
AND I YOU KNOW I WAS THERE. ON
CHRISTMAS DAY TWO YEARS AGO
WHEN THIS STARTED AND THE STAFF
THAT VOLUNTEER TO BE THERE I
HOPE YOU WILL EXPRESSED TO THEM
ARE INCREDIBLE THANKS. AWAY
FROM THEIR FAMILY THEIR
CHILDREN. OUTSIDE TO BE THERE
TO DO A REALLY WONDERFUL THING
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT- IDEA I WANT TO ASK YOU TO
TALK JUST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT-
THE WORK. AND ACCOMPLISHMENTS
AROUND CHILD TRAFFICKING THE
RESPONSE UNIT- AND HOW THE
UNIT- IS WORKING WITH THE
COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY EXPLOITED
CHILDREN ACTION TEAM. AND THE
CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL WHAT NEXT
STEPS TO YOU SO IF YOU JUST
GIVE ME KIND OF YOUR- BROAD.
STROKES ON THAT IT'S A ALSO A
AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
FOR VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS SO
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SENATOR AND YES WE HAVE. MADE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS MADE MAYBE
WANT TO JUST START WITH THE-
SIGNIFICANT CULTURE CHANGE THAT
THIS BODY AT WITH THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION MADE OF REALLY
RECOGNIZING YOUTH AS VICTIMS IN
THESE CASES AND- SO CERTAINLY
WE'VE BEEN DOING A LOT IN
LEARNING A LOT OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS- WE HAVE. IMPROVED
OUR ABILITY TO ACTUALLY HAVE
DATA COLLECTED SO WE'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN OVER SIX
THOUSAND. YOUTH A TRAFFIC AT
THAT WE ARE CAPTURING WE THINK
THAT POTENTIALLY COULD EVEN BE
AN UNDERCOUNT BASED ON- THAT
THE NEWNESS OF OUR ABILITY TO
DO THAT- WE HAVE REALLY BEEN
LOOKING AT BOTH THE TRAUMA
INFORMED APPROACHES KIND OF
MULTI DISCIPLINARY ACROSS ANY
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE. ACT WITH
THIS DELAY SPENDING YOUTH. WE
ALSO BELIEVE WRITING BUT TECH
ASSIST THE HARMONS MODEL REALLY
KNOWLEDGE THAT A MIGHT NOT BE.
THE FIRST TIME THAT THAT THE
YOUTH- LEADS THAT THAT THEY DID
HAVE THAT OPEN DOOR TO COME
BACK IN RETURN INFILL SUPPORTED
THEY WE WANT TO REDUCE THE
INSTANCES. AND ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE WORK IN SAN DIEGO
ON ON THAT APPROACH I THINK THE
OTHER P. THAT RELY IN AND HAVE
SEEN SOME PILOTS IN SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY. IT'S AROUND
THE TYPES OF PLACEMENT SO
HAVING SPECIALIZED TRAINING AND
SUPPORT AND IN A PLACE THAT
REALLY ACKNOWLEDGES AT SOME OF
THE TRAUMA THE SHEET HAVE
EXPERIENCE SO- THE CHILD WILL
FOR COUNSEL AS YOU MENTIONED
HAS A SET. A SUBCOMMITTEE
FOCUSED ON THIS EFFORT WHO IS-
ALSO SHARING IN DEVELOPING SOME
RESOURCES THAT CAN BE USED ON
THOSE MULTI MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAMS- WE I THINK HAVE A
SCRATCH THE SURFACE AND WE HAVE
MUCH MORE TO LEARN ABOUT THE
APPROACHES THAT AT WORK WITH
THE COMMUNITY BUT I THINK
AGAIN- IN OUR IN OUR FIRST-
ATTEMPTS AND LOOK AT. WHAT WE
KNOW IS WORKING IT IS THAT THIS
HARM REDUCTION MODEL IS
SUCCESSFUL IN THAT WE'RE NOT
CLOSING THE DOOR TO THE YOUTH.
WHO WE ACKNOWLEDGE MAY IT MAY I
MAY GO BACK TO THE TRAFFICKER
IN SOME CASES AND IN RETURN SO.
AGAIN IT'S A PLACE THAT I AM
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT IT'S A
PRIORITY OF THAT SECRETARY AS
WELL- AND MUCH MORE TO EXPLORE.
WONDERFUL WELL THANK YOU. I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE-
SENATOR MINING IN LOOKING AT
THE ORGANIZATIONAL CHART. YOU
KNOW YOU YOU WHAT WHAT A TASK
IN JOB YOU HAVE BUT ONE
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY I THINK
TO MAKE A REAL DIFFERENCE. FOR
THE LARGEST STAYED WITH SO MANY
COMPLEX ISSUES SEVERAL ARE
THANK YOU- WITH THAT I THINK WE
WILL MOVE TO- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. IN SUPPORT. I CAN%
ALREADY SEE THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE A LONG LINE OF FOLKS-
WHICH BODES WELL ALSO COMING UP
I WILL ASK YOU IF YOU CAN TO.
GIVE YOUR NAME- THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT AND
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE TO MORE
APPOINTMENTS YOUR SUPPORT-
COMMENTS VERY. IF ANY OKAY
WELCOME. I AM MY NAME IS MERRY
IGNATIUS I'M THE STATEWIDE
ORGANIZER OF. VOICES I HAD THE
HONOR AND PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
WITH- MISS JOHNSON WHEN SHE WAS
AT THE CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE.
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL NETWORK-
AND I THINK WHEN SHE LEFT
AUSTIN WENT TO CAME HERE TO
WORK IN THE DEPARTMENT- YOU
COULDN'T HAVE FOUND A BETTER
PERSON MORE QUALIFIED HER
EXPERIENCE ON THE GROUND HER
ABILITY TO. CENTER THE
EXPERIENCES OF FAMILIES IN IN
ALL OF HER DECISION MAKING- SHE
HAS BEEN- AN INCREDIBLE LEADER
AND- SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE
CAL OR PROCESS IN THE CAL WORK
SYSTEM SHE CREATED A PROCESS.
TO ENSURE THE FAMILIES WERE
ENGAGED AND SO RIGHT NOW IN A
TIME. OF YOU KNOW CRISIS AND
THE TIME OF FEAR THAT'S
HAPPENING AND FOR OUR MEMBERS
ARE PARENTS WERE LOW INCOME
PARENTS WHO USE. THE SERVICES
THAT SHOULD HER DEPARTMENT
ADMINISTERS THE NEED TO KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE A TRUSTED PERSON
AND A LEADER. AND THEY KNOW KIM
THEY KNOW HER AND THEY CAN
TRUST THAT AND- YOU COULDN'T
FIND A BETTER PROFESSIONAL.
CALM STEADY FOCUSED BRILLIANT
AND WE ARE JUST SO PROUD OF HER
AND ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES MA'AM.
I YES MY NAME IS LAURA THIS
WHOLE IDEA YEAH. THE SHORTEST
MY NAME IS THROUGH THIS CONE
AND I REALLY FEEL THAT ALL THE
EFFORTS THAT- MRS JOHNSON HAS
DONE FOR US EACH IS LIKE. I'M
AMAZING MY LIFE CHANGE I USED
TO BE A CON WORKS. I ANTI AND
NOW I'M MAD BECAME A TEACHER
AND- THE WAY THAT SHE ASSURED
CHILD CARE FOR ALL THE FAMILIES
AN OLD DEPARTMENTS OF MY GROUP
AND ALL THE PARENTS IS JUST
AMAZING SO I WANTED YOU REALLY
THANK HER FOR ALL THE THINGS
THAT SHE'S DONE FOR ME. AND
THINKER FOR LIKE ALSO MY FAMILY
ON BEHALF OF MY FAMILY BECAUSE
MY CHILDREN NOW ARE LIKE HAVING
A SECURE AND PROTECT THAT HOME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME KRISTIN POWER BUT THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
SIR PLEASURE TO SUPPORT THE
NOMINATION AND CONFIRMATION MS
JOHNSON AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HER TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT OUR FOSTER YOUTH AND
THEIR CAREGIVERS. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY CAROL
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IT'S BEEN A
PRIVILEGE TO WORK WITH CAME
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS AND
TENURE AT THE DEPARTMENT. THE
GOVERNOR COULD NOT HAVE PICKED
A BETTER PERSON- THAT WERE
REALLY LOOKING FOR TO OUR
CONTINUING COLLABORATION
PARTNERSHIP. AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO BE IN
GOOD HANDS HERE'S AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. HI WELCOME THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FRANK MAC EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OUR
MEMBERS ADMINISTER. THE LION'S
SHARE THE PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED
TO MS JOHNSON'S DEPARTMENT. AND
WE COULD NOT THINK OF A MORE
CREATIVE AND COMMITTED PARTNER
AND LEADER. ME VERY
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT HER
NOMINATION. THANK YOU. HI
WELCOME HI DINNING CULVER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION. SO OUR MEMBERS-
REPRESENT. THE WORKING POOR IN
THE MOST FRAGILE OF FAMILIES
AND KIDS CONNECTING UP THE KIDS
TO CHILDCARE EARLY LEARNING.
AND I HAVE TO SAY THAT WE ARE
SO HEARTENED BY THIS
NOMINATION. WE HAVE SOMEONE WHO
UNDERSTANDS THAT. TO
DEPARTMENTS TO BIG NON
MOVEABLE. ENTITIES NEED TO
MOVE. IN ORDER TO BETTER SERVE
FAMILIES SHE GETS SAID 'VE
BEEN WORKING IN THE TRENCHES.
SINCE TWENTY TWELVE WITH HER.
WE HAVE MOVEMENT AND CAL WORKS
LIKE WE'VE NEVER HAD BEFORE.
AND I LAY THAT AT HER FEET- AND
I CAN TELL YOU. THAT THEY'RE
GONNA BE SOME HARD ISSUES THAT
SHE DEALS WITH AND THERE'S
GONNA BE SOME PARADIGM SHIFTS
AND THE FACT THAT I KNOW THAT
SHE'S LEADING THE CONVERSATION
WILL WHOLEHEARTEDLY BE THERE AT
THE TABLE WITH HER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CATHERINE OCCUR
GONNA ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
BILLION FIRST HAVE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF MS JOHNSON'S
CONFIRMATION WE AT FIRST HAVE
CALIFORNIAN FIRST HEAVILY HAVE
WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH MISS
JOHNSON AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION. AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT ISSUES AND WE
BELIEVE THAT SHE BRINGS A
WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE EXPERTISE
AND EXPERIENCE TO THIS
POSITION. SHE HAS BEEN A
CHAMPION FOR STATE'S YOUNGEST
AND MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND WE ARE
PROUD TO SUPPORT HER TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON OVER SHE HAD THREE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
WE'RE HONORED TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT AT MS JOHNSON'S-
CONFIRMATION. WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
IS THAT HER WILLINGNESS TO-
ENGAGE WITH COUNTY STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE BEEN AMAZING I MEAN WHAT I
CAN PERSONALLY ATTEST TO THAT
OUR WILL IN THIS IS NOT ONLY-
FOR EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS BUT
IS ALSO FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
WORK. WITH HER AND FOR HER-
THAT WILLINGNESS TO HAVE AN
OPEN DOOR POLICY HAS LED TO
FLEE FOR FREE FLOWING
CONVERSATIONS AND IDEAS AND
SOLUTIONS FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
AT LARGE SO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HI WELCOME. I TIFFANY WITH
THAT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT- ON BEHALF OF
OUR SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS- DIRECTOR JOHNSON HAS
BEEN A LONGSTANDING CHAMPION
FOR CALIFORNIA FAMILIES AND
WORKERS AND WE SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THAT- OUR MEMBERS
ARE EXCITED AND PROUD TO
SUPPORT YOU. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED WORK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON DEBORAH
BROWN ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN OUT
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF MYSTERONS
CONFIRMATION WE'RE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT LOOKS AT HE
WHOLE LOT AT THE LIVES OF A
WHOLE CHILD IN AS WE THINK
ABOUT IT ACROSS POLICY AREAS
LIKE. CHILD WELFARE EARLY
LEARNING AND SUPPORT FOR
FAMILIES WE CAN IMAGINE IMAGINE
A BETTER CHAMPION WHO TO HAS
THAT SAME VISION AND SAME
DEDICATION. TO SUPPORTING-
FAMILIES AND KIDS AND WERE SO
PLEASED TO HAVE HER HERE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GET FREE MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ENTER SHANE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS ON BEHALF OF THE FOR
INFORMATICS. I UNDERSTAND
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS EXCUSE ME. ON BEHALF OF
THE FORTY ONE FOR BANKS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE'RE VERY PLEASED
TO SEE IN SUPPORT OF THE
NOMINATION- I WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT AND THAT MAY. THAT
MEANS SO MUCH TO THE STATE'S
EMERGENCY FOOD PROVIDERS AND I
WOULD JUST ECHO THAT. THAT
EXTENSIVE THE CONFERENCE
PROGRAM WHICH AS WE ALL KNOW IS
UNFORTUNATELY SUBJECT TO
SEVERAL ATTACKS IN OUR
COMMITMENT TO FIGURE OUT. HOW
TO MAXIMIZE THIS PROGRAM HOW
COMMISSION REVIEW PEOPLE IN
NEED- IS SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
MARTY A MODEM A FAMILY MEMBER
MY OLDER SISTER ELENA HAD
DEVELOPMENTAL. DISABILITIES
PHYSICAL DISABILITIES AND
RECEIVE. MEDI CAL I HSS AS WELL
AS REGIONAL CENTER SERVERS IN
MONTEREY ACTUALLY. BEFORE SHE
PASSED AWAY. AND SO MY FAMILY
KNOWS. WHEN THERE IS IN PLACE
AT THE STATE LEVEL- LEADERSHIP.
A DIRECTOR THAT CARES. AND SHE
IS DIRECTOR. JOHNSON EVEN
THOUGH YOU'VE ONLY SEARCH
SERVICE SHORT TIME. AS DIRECTOR
YOU HAVE SHOWN AND-
EXEMPLIFIED. OF BEAN
COLLABORATIVE. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO FAMILIES. AND
PEOPLE RECEIVE SERVICES
COMPASSIONATE. AND YOU BRING
THE CONFIDENCE. LINKED TO THAT
CONTEST ALL IMPORTANT TO ALL OF
US. WITHOUT IT WITH. TO THE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT IS SO
CRITICAL. AND YOU HAVE CONTINUE
TO TRADITION. BY THE PREVIOUS
DIRECTOR LEADERSHIP TEAM SO
JUST WANT TO SAY STRONG
SUPPORT. FROM FAMILIES AND
PEOPLE RECEIVE SERVICES. TO
DIRECTOR JOHNSON AND YOUR
FAMILY. MUST BE PROUD TO YOU.
BECAUSE WE ARE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY SEEING NO
OTHERS PEOPLE HERE IN SUPPORT I
MEAN IN OPPOSITION. OKAY MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN. THE DONATION
MADAM SECRETARY SENATORS BATES
BATES AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
ROTH ROTH I WILL WILK AYE
ATKINS HI IT'S UNANIMOUS
CONGRATULATIONS. OKAY WE'RE
GONNA SHIFT TO THE NEXT-
CONFIRMATION UNDERSECRETARY
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION MR AT YOUR AND
HELP ME HERE MCCUMBER PALMER
MACABRE. MISTER JEFFREY
MCCUMBER I WANT TO SAY WELCOME
WE'RE GONNA TAKE JUST A MINUTE
SO PEOPLE CAN EXIT AND WE CAN
THEN HEAR YOU.
SO LET ME SAY
WELCOME AND- INVITE YOU TO
RECOGNIZE ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE YOUR OPENING COMMENTS
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE RIGHT INTO
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. I'D LIKE WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE- MY WIFE CARL WHO'S
HERE- TO JOIN ME TAKING UP
GOING OFF IN THE FOURTH GRADE
WE LIKE TO SEE WHO YOU ARE
STAND UP THIS OUR FAVORITE PART.
WELCOME NUMEROUS MEMBERS OF MY
SEIZE OUR FAMILY HERE AS WELL
THANK YOU WELCOME. SO I GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I
BEGAN MY CAREER AS A STUDENT
ASSISTANT IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO SINCE THAT TIME I'VE HELD
VARIOUS POSITIONS IN THE
DEPARTMENT INCLUDING
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER
CORRECTIONAL BUSINESS MANAGER
CORRECTIONAL ADMINISTRATOR
CHIEF DEPUTY WARDEN WARDENS.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION
OF THE DOLE INSTITUTIONS IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN I WAS
FORTUNATE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE FOR A
SHORT TIME AS THE DIRECTOR OF
CORRECTIONS SERVICES AT THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WHICH ALLOW ME TO
VIEW THE QUESTION SYSTEM
THROUGH THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
FEDERAL RECEIVER IN CHARGE OF
HEALTH CARE. THIS COMBINED
EXPERIENCES LAY THE FOUNDATION
FOR MY CURRENT ROLE AS THE
UNDERSECRETARY OF
ADMINISTRATION AS THE
UNDERSECRETARY OVERSEE
APPROXIMATELY THREE THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES IN A VARIETY OF
POSITIONS INCLUDING FACILITIES
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY HUMAN
RESOURCES BUDGETS RESEARCH
TRAINING AUDITS INTERNAL
AFFAIRS TO NAME A FEW THE
DEPARTMENT TODAY IS
UNRECOGNIZABLE COMPARED TO THE
ONE I BEGAN WORKING FOR
NINETEEN NINETY TWO. THE RE
FOCUS OF OUR MISSION A
REHABILITATION OF PREPARING AND
MAYES FOR SUCCESSFUL COMMUNITY
REENTRY TO ENHANCE PUBLIC
SAFETY IS RESHAPED MANY ASPECTS
OF THE DEPARTMENT OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS. I FEEL GRATEFUL
TO. HAVE BEEN AND CONTINUE TO
BE PART OF THIS TRANSFORMATION
I LIKE TO THINK THE GOVERNOR
FOR POINTING ME IN THIS
CRITICAL ROLE. IN THE SENATE
FOR CONSIDERING MY APPOINTMENT.
AS TO SEE OUR IMPLEMENTS A
NUMBER OF CRITICAL INITIATIVES
IN THE COMING MONTHS I WILL
WORK WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADVANCE THE MISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT AS THE
UNDERSECRETARY OF
ADMINISTRATION. I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO AFFECT
CHANGE IN THIS NEW ROLE AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A SENATOR
ROTH LET ME START WITH YOU THIS
TIME. THANK YOU A MAN PRO TEM
MISTRANSLATED TERRY
CONGRATULATIONS. ARE YOU KNOW
AS UNDERSECRETARY OF
ADMINISTRATION- WITH OVERSIGHT
OVER HUMAN RESOURCES IN THIS.
RATHER HUGE ENTERPRISE IT YOU
CURRENTLY SERVE YOU HAVE A VERY
VERY DIFFICULT JOB. AS WE'VE
OUTLINED HERE IN IN OTHER
VENUES- BUT I'M- YOU HAVE AN
EXTRAORDINARY RESUME AND I'M
CERTAINLY GRATEFUL ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE AS WELL THAT YOU.
AGREED TO SERVE AND CONTINUE TO
SERVE- THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SO. I ABSOLUTELY HAVE NO
QUESTIONS OF LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING YOUR NOMINATION SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM. I AM
PARTIAL WE DO NOT GET AN
OPPORTUNITY- TO MEET BUT THAT'S
OKAY AND AGAIN I ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF SENATOR ROTH VERY
IMPRESSIVE. I DO HAVE A STATE
PRISON IN IN MY DISTRICT AND
WHEN I TALK TO THOSE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR OWN
HEALTH A AS WELL AS IS MENTAL
HEALTH. AND SO I'M JUST CURIOUS
WHAT YOUR VISION IS- PRETTY
LISA RELATES TO PEER SUPPORT
GROUPS WHICH IF YOU LOOK AT THE
DATA CERTAINLY SEEMS TO BE
WORKING. SO JUST. WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT ADDITIONALLY
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO ENSURE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS THESE
TYPE PROGRAMS AT EVERY PRISON.
THANK YOU. YEAH THIS WAS ONE OF
THE REASONS I WAS- MOST
ATTRACTED TO THIS POSITION WAS
THE EMPLOYEE WELLNESS ISSUE AND
THE FACT THAT WOULD OVERSEE
THAT WE DO HAVE YOUR SUPPORT
TEAMS AT ALL THIRTY FIVE
INSTITUTIONS- I'M HAPPY TO SAY
THAT THE I'M NOT HAPPY WE
RESPONDED TO FLUFF OVER
FOURTEEN HUNDRED CRITICAL
INCIDENT CALL OUTS THE PER
SUPPORT TEAMS RESPONDED TO LAST
YEAR- OUR TEAMS- ARE A DIVERSE
GROUP OF INTERVAL INDIVIDUALS-
CONSISTING OF RANK AND FILE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS TO
SUPERVISORS- TO HEALTH CARE
STAFF- IN SO IT'S AN ONGOING
CONCERN. WE HAVE A WILL BUS OF
ALMOST TEAM THAT WE'RE PUTTING
TOGETHER A HEADQUARTERS WHICH
NOW CONSISTS OF A SENIOR
PSYCHOLOGIST FOR SOCIAL WORKERS
AND TWO SERGEANTS THAT ARE
PURELY THERE TO SUPPORT FIELD-
MADE SOME OF THE DIFFICULTIES
THAT GO WITH- WORKING IN A
CORRECTIONAL ENVIRONMENT- SO
WE'RE COMMITTED TO WORK WITH
PARTNERS AND ORGANIZATIONS SURE
WE HAVE THE BEST PROGRAM WE-
HAVE. I JUST COULDN'T TO FIVE.
FOLLOW UP BY THAT. I'M SURE AT
EVEN THOUGH IT'S A QUITE
HELPFUL I'M SURE THERE'S REAL
LAW OF TIMES FROM OFFICER. TO
GET IN THERE MIGHT BE TRUST
ISSUES OR NO I DON'T NEED THIS
OR WHATEVER SO- WATER THIS
WATER DIFFERENT STRATEGIES A
PLAN TO EMPLOY A TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ACCESS THESE
SERVICES. YEAH YOU YOU ARE
CORRECT IN THAT- AT TIMES-
MEMBERS THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY ARE RELUCTANT TO COME
FORWARD TO DISCUSS MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES BECAUSE THERE IS
THERE'S A OF FEAR I THINK IT'S
UNFOUNDED- THAT COULD IMPACT
THEIR CAREER- OR PEER SUPPORT
PROGRAM- IS CONFIDENTIAL- WE
ALSO OFFER A NUMBER OF OTHER
SERVICES- THROUGH THE- EAP
PROGRAM THROUGH THE STATE- AS
WELL AS A LAW ENFORCEMENT
CHAPLAINCY SERVICE- ANOTHER
PART OF. NOW IS ALSO LOOKING AT
OTHER CREATIVE OPPORTUNITIES
SUCH AS A UTILIZING AN APP THAT
WOULD BE RUN BY AN INDEPENDENT-
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY THAT WOULD
HAVE A NUMEROUS WELLNESS AND
SUICIDE PREVENTION RESOURCES ON
IT WHERE WOULD HAVE TOTAL AN
AMENITY WERE WE- WOULD NOT KNOW
WHO IS ACCESSING THAT
INFORMATION SO- WITH THE GOAL
OF THE FOLKS FEEL COMFORTABLE
COMING FORWARD AND ASK. HEALTH
NEEDS. BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE WE
NEED TO GET TO. YEAH ANSWER AND
A LOOK FORWARD SUPPORTING A
CALL FOR. CENTER THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR SERVICE OVER THE YEARS
SIGE IT'S INTERESTING THAT
YOU'VE GOT KIND OF BEATEN WITH
THE BUG WHEN YOU WERE JUST IN
COLLEAGUES 
CAREER PATH AND CERTAINLY YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN IT ALL THE WAY
UP TO THE PRESIDENT AND THE
POTENTIAL OF FOR YOUR
APPOINTMENT TO THIS POSITION IS
EVIDENCE OF YOU KNOW YOUR
COMMITMENT THERE IN THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE
ON THE PEER SUPPORT PROGRAM I
MEAN READING THE STATISTICS OF.
WHAT TO OUR CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS HAVE TO FACE AND- THE
STRESSES AND OF THE SUICIDE
RATE FOUND REALLY HORRIFIC AND-
EYES SO EXCITING THAT YOU GOT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS FOR THEM
AND HAVE AT LEAST ARE YOU
ATTEMPTING TO ENSURE THAT MORE
PARTICIPATE IN DON'T WORRY
ABOUT STIGMA WORRY ABOUT YOUR
FAMILY AND YOUR LIFE SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT I JUST HAVE ONE
QUICK QUESTION BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE THE DO
FACE TO FACE AND IT'S ABOUT.
THE BUDGET IT JUST HOUSING
PRIEST EVEN THOUGH THE
POPULATION IAN OUR OB PRISONS
IS DOWN AND GIVE US A LITTLE
INSIGHT ON THAT OUT OF YOU KNOW
WHERE THE INCREASE IN MIGHT BE
FOR PROGRAMS THAT ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT A PERSONNEL WHATEVER.
I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM YOU ON
THAT YEAH IN OUR BUT IT HAS
SEEN SOME GROWTH IN A LOT OF
THAT IS TIED TO- COMPENSATION.
WE ALSO PULLED OUT NUMBER TWO
IN THIS IS IN THE APARTMENT OF
FORMER INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE
JUST PRO THAT WAS APPROVED BY
THE LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR THANK
YOU THAT WE ARE ROLLING OUT
BALLOTS ACTS UP AND RUNNING-
TWO THINGS LIKE THE TOILET
TREATMENT PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN
VERY EFFECTIVE WHILE. ALSO
SEEKING AND- OUR WORKERS
COMPENSATION COSTS- AS WELL AS
WE'VE HAD A NEW FOUND
COMMITMENT TO REHABILITATION
AND. ROLLED OUT. THE ABILITY TO
PROGRAMS IS ALSO HAD IN. ON THE
STATE BUDGET IS WELL BUT THE
ONE DRIVE BACK TOWARDS THE IMP
COMPENSATE. SOME THE AND HOW
PRO WE HAVE ROLLED OUT. THANK
YOU FOR THAT ANSWER AND ANSWERS
ALL OF MY QUESTIONS AND I WILL
CERTAINLY- SUPPORT YOU HAVE MY
FULL SUPPORT FOR YEAR ON A
PLANE THANK YOU CENTER. THEN
DEMONIC THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
WANT TO ADD MY CONGRATULATIONS
AND THANKS FOR YOUR SERVICE
ALSO WELCOME TO YOUR FAMILY AND
THANKS TO THEM. WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK I THINK THE
ONE QUESTION THAT WOULD BE OF
INTEREST TO THE PANEL IN THE
PUBLIC. ANY STEPS THAT YOU'RE
TAKING IN LIGHT OF THE CORONA
VIRUS IN WILL THERE BE A IMPACT
ON FAMILY VISITATION TO INMATES
OR ANY OTHER ANTICIPATED.
CONSEQUENCES THANK YOU CENTER-
YOU MORE- MODERATING THE
CROSSFIRE SITUATION VERY
CAREFULLY WE PARTICIPATE
DAILIES CALLS WITH OUR OTHER
PARTNERS CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AS WELL AS
CORD AND CLOSELY WITH A
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
HEALTHCARE SERVICES PARTNERS-
TO LOOK AT YOU KNOW WHAT ARE
STEP SHOULD BE- KNOCK ON WOOD
WE HAVE. NO CONFIRMED CASES OF
CORONAVIRUS IN THE PRISON
SYSTEM TO DATE- LIKE I SAID
WE'RE CLOSELY MONITORING NOW
WE'RE ENCOURAGING- BOTH STAFF
AND INMATES- TO INSURE- BEING A
PROPER HAND WASHING-
ENCOURAGING REGULAR CLEANING
OF- COMMON AREAS. OF BE AVOID
SHAKING HANDS OF SICK WITH YOUR
EMPLOYER TO MAKE DON'T GO TO
SCHOOL OR WHATEVER THE CASE MAY
BE- AND WERE REGULARLY ASKED
THE QUESTION AT LEAST A COUPLE
TIMES A DAY OF WHETHER WE'RE
GONNA CLOSE VISITING SO WE
DISCUSSED SAID EVERY DAY WE
HAVE NOT WAS VISITING AS F
YET- WHILE IS IT IS A CENTRAL
PATHWAY TO INTRODUCE. WE ALSO
THINK THE OPERATOR LIKELIHOOD
IS FOR CROSS OUR SCRIPTS AND
WE HAVE A THOUSAND PLUS STAFF
COMING THE GATE EVERY DAY. AND
THAT IS PROBABLY THE- LIKELY
SCENARIO WOULD BE OR DO IN THIS
IF IT IS ENERGY WE ARE
CONFIDENT WE HAVE- INEFFECTIVE
INFECTION CONTROL PLAN-
INFECTION DISEASE IN THE
PRESIDENT IS REALLY NOTHING NEW
FOR US WE ACTUALLY AVE
QUARANTINES GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
RANGING FROM MOBSTER
GASTROINTESTINAL. ISSUES TO
INFLUENCE A WHICH IS VERY
COMMON FOR US IN. I IMAGINE
CONSISTENT WITH THAT YOU CAN
ISOLATE IN IN ME- IN ANY OF THE
FACILITIES WHILE MAINTAINING
SECURITY. YES WE WOULD WE WOULD
WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS IN
MEDICAL TO LOOK AT WHETHER WAS
APPROPRIATE- PURSUE QUARANTINE
OR IN ISOLATION SETTING. AND IF
OBVIOUSLY IF AN INDIVIDUAL- WAS
SICK ENOUGH WE WOULD DO IS WE
DO NOW THEY WOULD THEY WOULD GO
OUT TO COMMITTEE HOSPITAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR SERVICE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR
MINING. I WANT TO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE- SENATOR BATES- ON
THE PEER SUPPORT EFFORTS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF. YOU
KNOW WHAT SENATOR MINING JUST
SAID ABOUT YET ONE MORE
STRESSOR ADDED TO- SITUATION SO
I WANNA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THAT IT REALLY
HAS TO START. AT THE TOP WITH
PEOPLE SAY AND THIS IS
APPROPRIATING GOOD AND PROVIDE
THAT SUPPORT SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THAT. I WANTED TO ASK-
IN LIGHT OF A AND I ALSO WANT
TO SAY HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE
THEIR BEEN CONVERSATIONS ABOUT-
BRINGING OUT OF STATE INMATES
BACK INTO CALIFORNIA- OBVIOUSLY
FOR MANY REASONS THAT'S GOOD.
AND WE STILL HAVE I THINK.
MAYBE A THOUSAND ARE YOU'LL
KNOW THE NUMBERS IN PRIVATE AT
CONTRACTED PRISONS IN LIGHT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S GOAL TO. CLOSE A
PRISON TELL ME HOW YOU SEE THAT
ARE THE I HATE WHEN WILL WE
ANTICIPATE NOT. USING OUR
PRIVATE CONTRACTED PRISON OR
WILL WE CONTINUE TO DO THAT
EVEN AS WE LOOK TOWARDS
POTENTIALLY A GOAL OF CLOSING A
PRISON DO YOU HAVE THOUGHTS ON
THAT I DO- IN THE CURRENT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE EXPECT TO
BE OUT OF ALL MALE PRIVATE
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES BY THE END OF APRIL.
OF THIS YEAR- WHICH WILL LEAVE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
CONTRACT- FEMALE BED STILL IN
PLACE- WE ARE LOOKING AT A
PROBABLY A TIME FRAME OF
EIGHTEEN TO THIRTY SIX MONTHS
TO BRING DOWN WAS FEMALE THAT
ONCE WE BRING. ME OVER RATE
WHICH IT LOOKS WE WILL AND
WE'RE- CAN BRING IN ADDITIONAL.
BEDS UP THE FEMALE PARTY THAT
WOULD ALLOW US TO CLOSE THOSE
FACILITIES IN A RELATIVELY
SHORT TIME PERIOD- THEN AFTER
WE COMPLETE THE CLOSURE OF THE
PRIVATE HEALTH FACILITIES WE
ALSO ARE LOOKING AT THE PUBLIC
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. AND ARE PROPOSING A
TAKE DOWN PLAN OF THOSE
FACILITIES OVER THE NEXT TWELVE
TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS. VERY
THANK YOU. I'M IDEA I HAVE TO
SAY- FROM THIS COMMITTEE- THE
SECRETARY'S BEEN INCREDIBLY
RESPONSIVE ON A NUMBER OF
ISSUES MORE THANK THE GOVERNOR
STAFF. BECAUSE WE'VE HAD
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT HAVE
YOU KNOW. IN PART OF CDC OURS
HISTORY YOU TALKED ABOUT A SEA
CHANGE WHEN YOU MADE YOUR- YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS AND IN A
NUMBER OF WAYS WHETHER IT'S-
SUPPORT UP HERE SUPPORT- BUT
ANY NUMBER OF ISSUES. BUT I DO
HAVE TO ASK YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT. A AND GET YOUR REACTION
TO REASSIGNING INVESTIGATIONS
OF STAFF COMPLAINTS THAT COULD
RESULT IN DISCIPLINARY ACTION-
SO THAT IS NOT BE IN A SUMMER
NOT BEING HANDLED AT THE
FACILITY BUT OF A BROADER
APPROACH. CAN YOU GIVE ME SOME
COMMENTS ON THAT I THINK. IT
YOU KNOW. YOU KNOW WE GET
REPORTS OF FREQUENTLY ABOUT
AUDITS AND INVESTIGATIONS AND I
THINK SOMETIMES THOSE ARE
DIFFICULT BECAUSE YOU DON'T
ALWAYS GET THE PERSPECTIVE FROM
HOW IT ACTUALLY WORKS ON THE
GROUND SO I WANT TO. I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT BUT IN TERMS
OF HOW THESE- COMPLAINTS ARE
HANDLED INVESTIGATIONS ARE
DONE. SOME THOUGHT PROCESSES
ABOUT HOW THIS WILL BE. A
PROCESS THAT REALLY PUTS IT IN
THE HANDS OF SOMEONE WHO CAN
MAKE THE DETERMINATION AND IT
ISN'T THE STAFF INVESTIGATING
INCIDENTS THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE
EVEN. HAD MORE KNOWLEDGE OF OUR
BEEN PART OF OUR YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M REFERRING TO SO MAYBE YOU
CAN. BE A SO WE RECEIVED
APPROVAL APPROVAL AND THE
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET TO-
ESTABLISH OUR ALLEGATION
INQUIRY MANAGEMENT SECTION
WHICH- BASICALLY- ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT. TO WHEN IT WHEN IT
MAY FOLLOWS A STAFF COMPLAINT
THAT MEETS THE CRITERIA IS A
STAFF COMPLAINT- TO PULL THE
REVIEW OF THAT COMPLAIN THAT IS
NOW DONE WITHIN THE PRISON BY
PRISON STAFF THAT WILL BE DONE-
BY AN EXTERNAL GROUP- THE
REPORTS UP TO OUR OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS. SO WE HAVE
HIRED A NUMBER OF LIEUTENANTS
THAT WILL BE GOING OUT AND THEY
WILL BE DOING THE REVIEW IN THE
INQUIRY OF THOSE COMPLAINTS-
BUT I THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
PIECES OF WILL BE DONE BY
SOMEONE THAT- AT THE PRISON OR
STORE THE INDIVIDUAL SIDE WILL
NOT BE ONE THAT HAS WORKED AT
THAT PERSON. AND WE HAVEN'T OF
INDEPENDENCE THEY WILL
PARROTING COREY REPORT- THAT
WILL TEN GO BACK TO THE
CAPTAIN THAT OVERSEES THAT
LIEUTENANT- FOR FORTY NOW
REPORT ON TO HARD IT'S ALREADY
DETERMINE WHERE THAT. IT'S A
FULL SCALE OFFICE INTERNAL
AFFAIRS INVESTIGATION WHEN THE
CORRECTIVE ACTION IS REQUIRED
OR IF THE COMPLAIN APPEARS TO
BE UNFOUNDED.AND SO WE'RE VERY
MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO ROLL
THIS OUT WE EXPECT THE
REGULATIONS TRICKLE IN EFFECT
APRIL FIRST. WHICH IS ALSO THE
SAME TIME WILL BE ROLLING. OUT
OR ELECTRONIC TRACK THROUGH OUR-
VENDOR MAY. SYSTEM OF THE SAME
WHICH ALLOWS GENERATE VARIOUS
REPORTS- DEFY TRENDS AND REALLY
GET A PULL SO WHAT'S GOING ON
INSTITUTIONS. THANK YOU. I CAN
I A- ASK IF. IN AN APPROPRIATE
PERIOD OF TIME DOWN THE ROAD
YOU KNOW. SIX MONTHS OUR
THEREAFTER AND I HAVE LOOK AT
STAFF TO TRACK- WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO GIVE US OUR AS A
RESPONSE AND REACTION TO HOW
YOU THINK THAT IS WORKING-
SALUTE WE ARE I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT- AND SO WILL
PROBABLY FOLLOW UP IN AND- SEND
YOU A LETTER AND LET YOU KNOW
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE. THAT JUST
SO WE ARE INFORMED AND KEEP
TRACK- AND UNDERSTAND HOW YOU
THINK IT'S WORKING RIGHT. OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS IF NOT LET
ME TURN TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT- OF THE
CONFIRMATION DAY PLEASE COME ON
UP. A WE HAVE A MICROPHONE YOU
CAN NOW GIVE US YOUR NAME. THE
HAT YOU MIGHT BE WEARING TODAY-
FIGURATIVELY- IT AND YOUR
POSITION YOUR POSITION OF
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS I
AM CORRECTIONAL OFFICER NEIL
FLOOD- I AM THE RANK AND FILE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AND I AM HERE TODAY
TO SUPPORT JEFF MCCUMBER. IHAVE KNOWN JEFF MCCUMBER SINCE
ABOUT HALFWAY UP HIS LIST OF
ALL OF THE JOBS OF THESE FELT.
AND WORKED WITH THEM SINCE THEN
BUT WE- SERIOUSLY- SUPPORT JEFF
IN HIS OPEN DOOR POLICY AND HIS
DESIRE TO WORK WITH US AND
UNDERSTAND OUR POSITION OF OUR
MEMBERS- WE HAVE ALMOST THIRTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS WORKING INSIDE
THE FACILITIES. AND OUTSIDE- WE
DON'T ALWAYS SEE EYE TO EYE
WITH MR MCCUMBER BUT HIS DOOR
IS ALWAYS OPEN AND HE DOES SEEK
OUR INPUT AND AT TIMES CHANGES
THE DIRECTION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION
AS IT RELATES TO THE ISSUES
THAT AFFECT OUR MEMBERSHIP. SO
WE ENCOURAGE AND I'D VOTE FOR
JEFF THE COVERS CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. WELCOME SEVEN
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS COREY
CELLS- ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT. MR
MCOMMERCE NOMINATION WITH A
SHORT TIME TO WORK TOGETHER
BUT- IN THAT TIME IT'S BEEN
VERY FRUITFUL AMONG THE
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM MEASURES
FROM JAILS AS YOU KNOW. AND SO
THE ABILITY TO WORK TOGETHER
WITH MISTER MECOM OR THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE CDC OUR
EXECUTIVE TEAM ESPECIALLY. OUR
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THOSE
EFFORTS OF THANK YOU- AND
WIENER DRIVE OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. SENATOR
ROTH YOU WANT TO REGAIN YOUR-
YEAH THIS. VERY GOOD MADAM
SECRETARY SENATE RACE HI BATES
AYE MONNING AYE MONNING AYE
ROTH ROTH FIVE WILK WILK AYE
ATKINS. FIVE CONGRATULATIONS
UNANIMOUS. OKAY A WELCOME-
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE INTO THE
DIRECTOR OF OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW A. N. O.
WELCOME KENNETH POGUE. YES OKAY
I EVEN KNOW WHY. FINAN IF. YOU
GOT BONTA. HEY IT AND THAT'S
WHAT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT TO-
IT'S BEEN A LONG WEEK IT'S ONLY
WEDNESDAY- I WANT TO SAY
WELCOME AND- INVITE YOU TO
RECOGNIZE PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE-
OPENING COMMENTS AND THENWE'LL
GO RIGHT INTO THE COLLEAGUES ON
THE ON THE RULES COMMITTEE
WELCOME. MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- FIRST THANK YOU YOUR
STAFF FOR TAKING TIME TO GET TO
KNOW ME. IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE.
I'D LIKE TO FIRST INTRODUCE-
OUR NEW. SECRETARY OF THE
GOVERNOR UPPER OPERATIONS
ORGANIZATION JANA RICHARDSON'S
WHO WHO WITH THEIR TEAM IS HERE
TO SUPPORT ME TODAY AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THAT
TEAM- I'D LIKE TO THINK THE
GOVERNOR FOR- THE SUPPORT IN
AND POINT ME IN THIS POSITION
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY I'D LIKE
pCUTLER. WHO'S BEEN LOOKING
FORWARD TO STANDING UP TODAY
DINNER IS FOR SOME. WELCOME
WITHOUT JENNIFER SUPPORT I
COULDN'T DO THIS TYPE OF JOB
AND- AND SHE'S BEEN MY PARTNER
FOR YEARS AND I CAN'T SAY HOW
MUCH I APPRECIATE HER- POSSIBLE
INCREDIBLY GOOD INTRODUCTION.
WERE OR WERE NOTING THAT SHOULD
I STOP. DOBBS ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW IS A SMALL ORGANIZATION
WITH A REALLY LARGE MISSION
AND- WHEN I WAS A CLIENT THAT
AGENCY AND- OVERSEEN
REGULATIONS FOR THE PARMA
CORRECTIONS WORKING WITH THOSE
ATTORNEYS I'D ENVISIONED THIS
LARGE CADRE OF STAFF AND
ATTORNEYS THERE BECAUSE OF THE
DETAIL. THAT THEY GAVE TO THEIR
ANALYSIS AND THEIR EXPLANATIONS
AND THEIR HELP- WAS SO HUGE I
JUST EXPECTED TO BE A LOT MORE
OF THEM SO I WAS A LITTLE
SURPRISED WHEN I GOT OVER THERE
TO SEE HOW SMALL THE ORG CHART
WAS- WHILE THEY STILL CONTINUE
TO MEET THEIR MISSION. AND SO
MY GOALS FOR THE LOS MINISTER
OF LAW FOR ONE IS JUST CONTINUE
THAT EXCELLENCE- TO ENSURE THAT
MY ORGANIZATION CONTINUES TO
REVIEW IN A TIMELY FASHION-
BOTH- THIS MISSION OF
REGULATIONS AND EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS- AS WELL AS-
OVERSIGHT AND DETERMINATIONS ON
UNDERGROUND REGULATION
PETITIONS. AND I THINK OF
UTMOST IMPORTANCE I'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE AND EXPAND OUR
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
MOST STATE EMPLOYEES MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC AND- LEGISLATIVE
STAFF. AND THE WORKING ON THAT
I CONTINUOUSLY SINCE I'VE BEEN
THERE I THINK EDUCATION. ON
REGULATIONS AND HOW TO.
APPROPRIATELY PROMULGATE THEM-
IS OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE AND SO
I PLEDGETO YOU THEY'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK AS LONG AS I'M
IN THIS POSITION- TO BOTH
CONTINUE THE EXCELLENCE BUT AS
WELL AS IT BRING THAT
INFORMATION OUT TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC AND THE STAFF. THE
WORK ON THIS TYPE OF A
REGULATORY A LOT AND SO I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
I'M REALLY HAPPY TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU. YOUR START SENATOR
MONNING. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MISTER POPE THANK YOU WE
HAD A GOOD CONVERSATION-
YESTERDAY AND- WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND THANK
YOU YOUR WIFE IN COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR SUPPORT MAYBE JUST TO
EXTENDING A LITTLE THE
FOUNDATION YOU JUST LAID- I
THINK MANY OF US AREN'T
FAMILIAR WITH. BOTH WHAT YOU'RE
TASKED WITH IN YOUR DEPARTMENT
IN THE RESOURCES YOU HAVE TO DO
THAT AND SO I THINK IN OUR
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY- I CAN
ASK YOU IF YOU HAD A MAGIC WAND.
QUOTE WOULD BE THE- LET'S JUST
SAY THE MORE IDEAL- STAFFING A
RESOURCES YOU RECEIVE- YOU WORK
WITH AGENCIES. IN REVIEWING
PROPOSED RATINGS YOU PROVIDE
THE LEGAL ANALYSIS AND FEEDBACK
SOMETIMES THOSE ARE TESTED IN
THE COURTS YOUR TEAM IS LAWYERS
AND SUPPORT STAFF- MAYBE GIVE
US A LITTLE BETTER VISION OF
KIND OF THE TREADMILL THAT
YOU'RE ON IN IN THE CHALLENGES
WHEN. A STAFF PERSON OR A
COUPLE STAFF PEOPLE HAVE TO GET
ASSIGNED TO A PARTICULAR.
CRISIS OR IMMEDIATE NEED AND
HOW THAT AFFECTS THE FLOW OF
THE BROADER MISSION OF THE
OFFICE CERTAINLY. SO WE
GENERALLY GET TWO TYPES OF
REGULATIONS HELLO THERE SOME
EXCEPTIONS BUT WE HAVE THE
NORMAL REGULATORY PROCESS WHERE
WHEN WE RECEIVE A REGULATION
AND WE HAVE THIRTY DAYS TO
CONDUCT A REVIEW. ATTRACT MANY
CHANGES TO WORK WITH THE
ORGANIZATION SUBMITTING THOSE
REGULATIONS AND TO HOPEFULLY
APPROVE THEM AT THE END OF THE
DAY- IN SOME INSTANCES WERE
LEFT WITH THE ONLY OPTION BEING
DISAPPROVAL- BUT EVEN THEN MY
ATTORNEYS WORK WITH FAT
ORGANIZATION. TO ENSURE THAT
THE CHANGES ARE MADE THE PROPER
NOTICE IS GIVEN TO THE PUBLIC-
AND THEN HOPEFULLY THEIR
RESUBMITTED TO US WHERE WE CAN
APPROVE THAT- THE OTHER COMMON
TYPE OF REGULATION IS AN
EMERGENCY REGULATION OR WE ONLY
HAVE TEN DAYS INCLUDING
WEEKENDS AND HOLIDAYS. IN WHICH
TO CONDUCT A REVIEW AND SO A
LOT OF THOSE OF EXTREME
IMPORTANCE TO THE STATE AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND SO WE
HAVE TO GO ALL HANDS ON DECK AT
THAT TIME TO REVIEW THOSE AND
GET THEM DONE THAT TEN DAY
PERIOD- I CURRENTLY HAVE ELEVEN
REVIEWING ATTORNEYS- THAT
HANDLE THOSE I RECEIVE- OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED. REGULATION
PACKAGES PER YEAR SELECT
DIVIDING THAT UP AMONGST THOSE
ELEVEN. AT THE SAME TIME ONE OF
THOSE ATTORNEYS IS ASSIGNED TO
MY UNDERGROUND REGULATIONS
UNIT- WHERE THEY ARE DEALING
WITH PETITIONS- FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC AND INTERESTED
PARTIES- CHALLENGING- ALLEGED
UNDERGROUND REGULATIONS THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN PROMULGATED
THROUGH THE APA PROCESS. SO
WHAT I'M REALLY LEFT WITH THIS
TEN ATTORNEYS TO SPLIT UP THOSE
A HUNDRED OR SO- REGULATION
FILES- AND SO. I WISH I HAD A
MAGIC WAND AND I WOULD
CERTAINLY BE WAVING AT. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE A
DIFFICULTY WITH HIS IN ASKING
FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IS WE
DON'T FAIL. IN MEETING THOSE
REGULATORY TIME FRAMES. AND
WHAT THAT MEANS IS WE GET A LOT
OF REGULATIONS IN ITS LAST TIME
PER REGULATION THAT WE CAN
SPEND- ON EACH OF THOSE
REGULATIONS AND SO. IT'S
DIFFICULT TO COME UP WITH SOME
SORT OF ARGUMENT THAT WE'RE
FEELING THEIR MISSION BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES BUT
WHAT I THINK. EVERYONE ELSE TO
RECOGNIZE AND I'LL DO MY BEST
ADVOCATE FOR IS THAT. WE COULD
CERTAINLY DO MORE IN THAT TIME
FRAME IF WE HAD RESOURCES TO DO
IT- NE OF THE THINGS THAT THAT
I'VE IMPLEMENTED THAT. IS SO
FAR HAS BEEN VERY POPULAR BUT I
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO DO
IT VERY OFTEN IS EARLY
INTERVENTION WHERE ONE OF MY
SENIOR ATTORNEYS AS A SIGN TO A
FILE. IN ADVANCE OF THE FILING
COMING TO AL- WHERE THEY'RE
GIVING GUIDANCE ON ENSURING
THAT DUE PROCESS IS AVAILABLE
TO INTERESTED PARTIES. AND THAT
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE EIGHT
PM MATT MATT STREAMLINES A PART
OF THAT PROCESS AND RESULTS IN
A BETTER REGULATION. IF I HAD
MY MAGIC WAND I THINK I'D WAIVE
IT TO HAVE A SMALL TEAM OF
EXPERIENCE ATTORNEYS WHO COULD
DO MORE OF THAT TYPE OF WORK.
BUT I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT WITH
THE BUDGET. BEING WHAT IT IS
AND- WITH THE CONCERNS THAT WE
DISCUSSED WITH THE CORONA
VIRUSES AFFECTING THE ECONOMY I
KNOW THAT'S A VERY DIFFICULT
THING TO ASK FOR- BUT I WILL BE
MONITORING THE HANDS AND
HOPEFULLY COMING FORWARD WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE FUTURE.
WELL THANK UNITS ONE OF MY
TAKEAWAYS FROM OUR CONVERSATION
WAS. GIVEN THE CHALLENGES IN
MAY RELATIVELY LIMITED
RESOURCES- YOU SHARED WITH SOME
ENTHUSIASM THE ESPRIT DE CORPS
OF THE TEAM THE WORK WITH HIM.
THAT THAT'S KIND OF MY FINAL
QUESTION I THINK WOULD BE GOOD
TO SHARE SOME OF THAT I WAS.
IMPRESSED WITH THE ENTHUSIASM
THAT YOU HAVE FOR YOUR TEAM IN
THE WORK THAT YOU DO. I THANK
YOU I HAVE AN AMAZING TEAM OF
ATTORNEYS WITH YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE AND- COSTLY WALKING
DOWN THE HALL WITH THESE
EMERGENCY AISLES AND I. GET
VOLUNTEERS FOR WORK. I NEVER
HAVE. I GET A FADE WHEN I HAVE
OFF THESE REALLY MESSY FIVE. OR
RESULT IN A LOT OF WORK AND IF
I COULDN'T HAVE A BETTER TEAM
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE BEST
THINGS ABOUT WORKING THERE IS
HOW POSITIVE. EVERYONE IN THAT
UNIT IS AND IT'S REALLY PART OF
A SMALL ORGANIZATION LIKE THAT
WITH THAT. BUT I CONTINUE THAT
POSITIVENESS AND ALL SUPPORT
COMMITTEE WHERE I CAN. THANK
YOU IN WE JUST ASK THAT YOU
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION TO ALL
OF YOUR TEAM IN. APPRECIATE
YOUR STEPPING UP. TO THIS NEW
CHALLENGE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
NOMINATION AND ARE YOU HAVE A
FAN ON ALL THAT HAPPENS TO BE
SITTING RIGHT NEXT TO ME KIND
OF- I DID HAVE A CHANCE TO MEET
DIRECTLY WITH YOU THAT TIME I
BELIEVE HE'S KNOWN YOU QUITE
AWHILE AND GAVE YOU A FIVE STAR
SO. I'M GOOD WITH THAT BUT I'M
GLAD THAT YOU DID A DRESSY
UNDERGROUND REGULATIONS THAT IS
AN ISSUE I IN TERMS OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF BY NOT GOING
TO THE REGULAR PROCESS AND THAT
YOU'RE WORKING ON THAT IN YOU
WILL HAVE CERTAINLY MY
ATTENTION TO RESOURCES BECAUSE
WE ARE GETTING- I WON'T COME
COMPLAINTS BUT CONCERNS FROM
PROVIDERS IN ISSUES ON THAT IN
THAT VERY ROUND SO- WILL GIVE
YOU A YOU KNOW THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE MORE OF THAT WITH US
AS YOU GO FORWARD. AND YOU WILL
HAVE MY- MY OWN HIGH FIVE- FOUR
YEAR CONFIRMATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LOOK COMES UP THANKS
A LOT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A-
HAVE A GREAT STAFF TO BY THE
WAY AT THE RULES COMMITTEE AND
THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE. STAFF
AND MEMBERS IN SUPPORT WE LIKE
TO GIVE- CHRIS A HARD TOP- BUT
HE'S NOT EASY BY THE WAY. WE
JUST ASSURE YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM WORLD CHRIS BURNS
ENDORSEMENTS IS GOOD ENOUGH.
I'M GOING TO FOREGO ANY
QUESTIONS AND PLAN TO SUPPORT
YOUR NOMINATION CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU. SENATOR ROTH THANK
YOU MAYOR PRO TEM OF MORE
CONGRATULATIONS AND I NTEND TO
OBVIOUSLY SUPPORT THE
NOMINATION I'M JUST CURIOUS
HOWEVER WHEN THE- OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW DETERMINES
THAT A STATE AGENCY. SIR WORKS
UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR ISSUE SOMETHING THAT
YOU DETERMINED TO BE AN
UNDERGROUND REGULATION IN OTHER
WORDS IT WAS IMPROPERLY
PROMULGATED AND SHE WAS IN THE
AGENCY FAILED TO FOLLOW THE
PROCEDURES SET FORTH IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT.
WHY SHOULD. SOMEONE THIRD PARTY
HAVE TO GO TO THE SUPERIOR
COURT. IN ORDER TO GET A
DETERMINATION THAT SETS ASIDE
THAT REGULATION. VERY FOR
QUESTION WHY SHOULDN'T WHY
SHOULDN'T THE ADMINISTRATION ON
IT. AND DIRECT AN AGENCY TO
CORRECT SOMETHING THAT IS
OBVIOUSLY IMPROPER THAT YOU IN
YOUR AGENCY YOUR OFFICE HAVE
DETERMINED TO BE IMPROPER. A
FAIR QUESTION- I DO REPORT-
BOTH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
GOVERNOR OPERATIONS WHEN THESE
OCCURRENCES HAPPEN IN MOST
INSTANCES WE FIND THAT THE
AGENCY OR DEPARTMENT- WHEN WE
MADE A DETERMINATION-
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT AND GIVES US
WHAT'S CALLED A SECTION TWO
EIGHTY A NOTIFICATION THEY WILL
NO LONGER BE ENFORCING THOSE-
IT'S VERY RARE AND HASN'T
HAPPENED SINCE I'VE BEEN THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW- WHERE AN
AGENCY HAS. REFUSED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE FOUND THAT
IT'S AN UNDERGROUND REGULATION-
BUT THEY'RE ALSO SHOULD BE THAT
BROADER OPPORTUNITY IT
SHOULDN'T JUST BE WITHIN- ELVES
ARE SMALL RESOURCES- INDIVIDUAL
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GO TO
SUPERIOR COURT TO ENFORCE THEIR
RIGHTS WHEN I MAY DISAGREE WITH
YOU. AND THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
TAKE THAT TO THE COURT CERTAIN
RIGHT BUT IN THE CASES WHERE
THERE'S NO DISAGREEMENT WHERE
YOU'VE ISSUED A DETERMINATION
THAT THE REGULATION IS AN
UNDERGROUND REGULATION AND WAS
IMPROPERLY PROMULGATED UNDER
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES
ACT. IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES YOU
FIND THAT THERE ARE NO CHIP
THERE REALLY AREN'T CHALLENGES
ON THE ON THE ON THE NORM IN
SUPERIOR COURT. I HAVE SEEN
SEPARATE CHALLENGES OR WE
HAVEN'T BEEN INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS WHERE WE HAVE BEEN
ISSUED A CHANCE BUT NO EVERYONE
THAT I HAVE SEEN THIS COME TO
US WHERE WE'VE MADE A
TERMINATION. THE AGENCY OR
DEPARTMENT HAS ACKNOWLEDGED AND
HAS HAS STOPPED ENFORCING THOSE
THEY DO THAT THROUGH WHAT WE
CALL SECTION TWO EIGHTY WHERE
THEY- OFFICIALLY ACKNOWLEDGE-
THAT THEY WILL NO LONGER BE
ENFORCING THOSE RULES PERFECT
WITH THANK YOU FOR DOING WHAT
YOU DO AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING YOUR- CONFIRMATION-
THANK YOU. CAN I ASK A IN TERMS
OF WHAT THE INFORMATION I HAVE
IN FRONT OF ME THEIR NON
UNDERGROUND REGULATION- OF
PETITIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
UNDER REVIEW. UNDERGROUND
REGULATION PETITIONS AND EIGHT
OF THOSE ARE CDC ARE CAN I JUST
CORRECT ME IF THAT'S NOT
ACCURATE YOU'VE HAD LOTS OF
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE WITH CDC
ARE CAN YOU. WHY DO YOU BELIEVE
THE DEPARTMENT ACCOUNTS FOR SO
MANY OF THE UNDERGROUND
ELECTION TISH. OR THAT JUST
PART OF THAT IS DONE NOW. ISSUE
THE- AND FAMILY OUTSIDE COUNSEL
FOR THOSE PRISONERS HAVE BEEN A
REALLY GOOD JOB EDUCATING- THE
PRISONERS AT CDC ARE ON THE
METHODS NECESSARY TO CHALLENGE-
SO E GET A LARGE VOLUME OF
THEM SOMETIMES WE ACCEPT THEM
BECAUSE THEY'RE CORRECT. A LOT
OF TIMES- THEIR PROCEDURALLY
DEFICIENT OR THAT USES AN
UNDERGROUND REGULATIONS A LOCAL
RULE OR SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS TO FOR A
FIGHTING UNDERGROUND
REGULATION. SO THE VOLUME IS AS
EXPECTED THE HIGHEST FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS BUT-
IN LARGE PART IS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY ALLOW THOSE
INMATES TO UNDERSTAND THE
PROCESS TO BE INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS. THAT'S AN INTERESTING-
UNDERSTANDING TO HALF THANK YOU.
IF NOTHING FURTHER- LET ME ASK
FOLKS IN SUPPORT MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK. IT YOU KNOW THAT
COULD BE GOOD I. WE'VE HAD
EXPERIENCE IN THIS- ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. WONDERFUL THANK YOU
SO MUCH MADAM SECRETARY
SENATORS BATES BATES AYE
MONNING MONNING AYE ROTH ROSS I
WILL WILK AYE ATKINS HI. LET ME
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES I A I
REALLY HAVE ENJOYED YOUR
ENTHUSIASM- TODAY AND IT SHOWS
OBVIOUSLY SO UNANIMOUS
CONFIRMATION CONGRATULATIONS
YOU.
NINE YEAH WHAT. SO WE'RE
GONNA- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION FOR ONE ITEM
AND THEN WERE GOING TO ALSO
THEN GO INTO CLOSED SESSION SO
STAFF HERE FOR EXECUTIVE ADMIN
WILL ASK FOLKS TO LEAVE FOR A
BRIEF- CLOSE SESSION SO WITH
THAT IN- EXECUTIVE SESSION WE
HAVE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN-
APPOINTMENT TO THE.